[موسيقى]
اتوقع انه المنتخب السعودي سيواصل مسيرته
الان اصبحت الامور صعبه جدا
المسؤوليه اصبحت كبيره جدا امام منتخب
بولندا اعتقد ان المنتخب السعودي رح يكمل
المسيره
بالفوز على المنتخب البولندي او على الاقل
التعادل
[موسيقى]
سر التطور بكل امانه يعود مدرب المنتخب
السعودي لافضل انا اكثر من ثلاثه او سنتين
مع المنتخب السعودي
مجموعه
عن طريق اليابان واستراليا والصين كذلك
حضور لاعب الاجنبي ايضا اضاف همم قوه
للاعب السعودي بسبب الاحتكاك بسبب التعامل
بسبب همم
الصراع القوي على الخانه مع الاجانب في
ذلك استطاع المنتخب السعودي اللاعب
السعودي ان يطور مستواه الى الامام اعتقد
انه المنتخب السعودي همم سيواصل همم
انتصاراتها باذن الله تعالى همم الى
الامام
[تصفيق]